i grew up thinking it would be easy
figuring out my life's journey
as if doors would just open for me
university a job a family
a happy life
however
i'm in my twenties and starting to
realize that it's not so simple
this is where odyssey plans can really
help
what would my future life look like if i
went through this door instead of that
one
bill burnett and dave evans designed an
odyssey plan template to help us
identify key milestones in the next five
years of our lives we're going to look
at three different scenarios and take a
look at what our future might hold
our first possible future is what we see
ourselves doing in the next five years
if everything goes to plan in my plan i
would like to build on my experience of
doing environmental work with the
european solidarity corps
perhaps in the first year i'll start an
internship at the botanical garden and
learn more about slovenia's ecosystem
next year i could start a job in the
flower industry to gain more experience
and money
draft my own business plan in the third
year
investigate loans for small businesses
in the fourth and towards the end of the
fifth i might be close to opening my own
flower shop
however
things rarely go perfectly to plan
in my case
maybe working with plants just isn't my
thing this leads us to the second
odyssey plan
the scenario in which something has
changed and our first plan is no longer
an option maybe i want to stay connected
to the european solidarity core from a
people point of view
i could look for jobs with a local
hosting organization this year and begin
a career working to make sure more young
people get the opportunity to live and
work abroad
who knows
maybe in five years i'll be working for
an european institution on policies that
directly affected people like myself
in the final scenario we're going to
think about what would we do if money
was no longer an issue in this life
perhaps i want to go back to
volunteering
i could become an environmental activist
maybe try my hand at riding an
eco-friendly travel block for young
people
now that we have our three different
plans we must assess the following
do we possess the resources to make this
happen
how confident are we that this can
happen does the plan truly match what we
want to do
how enthusiastic are we about it
finally we're going to give each plan a
name
like the flower plan
the youth career plan and the echo
blogger plan
and write down questions we have for
each one
for instance
if i want to start my own business
can i afford to take holidays the year
before
there are infinite choices in life
and perhaps none of your plans will
fully come to fruition
but the whole point is to be prepared
and know that you have options for when
life puts an obstacle in your path